So basically we're living in the future, we’ve
got computers in our pockets, we can facetime
with people across the world, and a hyperloop
train is on the way... but I want to know
where the hell is my jetpack!?
hey guys Julia here for DNews
SOOON.
It’s coming soon.
By the middle or end of next year!
But the company is based in New Zealand.
Sooo looks like I’ll start looking at plane
tickets.
The Martin jetpack is the brainchild of Glenn
Martin, which he first starting imagining
way back in the early 80s.
Since then it’s been through a few iterations
but this latest version runs on good old fashioned
gasoline.
The gasoline powers twin ducted fans that
provide the downward thrust necessary to lift
a person.
The frame is made from lightweight carbon
fiber and aluminum.
The company’s website claims it can reach
heights of over 3,280 feet and soar around
for about half an hour.
And it’s only for the low low low price
of 200,000 bucks.
But who would want that?
Okay okay, you you probably would.
Though the price might make it out of reach
for the average Joe to play around with.
But it’s not just fun and games, these were
also designed with emergency responders in
mind.
Mike Read, director of flight operations at
Martin Aircraft Co. said, "With its small
dimensions, it can operate in confined spaces,
close to and between buildings, near trees
or in other areas that large or very tall
aircraft, such as helicopters, can't access."
So that could be pretty cool if not slightly
expensive.
So why exactly aren’t we all just zooming
around in jetpacks yet?
Well when you think of a jet pack, I bet you
imagine a rocket pack.
The harness that straps on your back with
two tanks that shoot massive amounts of fire
out of the bottom.
Right?
These kind of jet packs could work by combining
fuel and an oxidizing agent.
When the fuel and the oxidizing agent, maybe
hydrogen maybe liquid oxygen, mix it creates
a lot of heat. and WOOSH you’d get the hot
flames shooting out the bottom to lift the
person into the air.
Okay, but let’s get real.
They are not the greatest idea.
Like WHO WANTS ROCKET FUEL BURNING BY THEIR
NETHER REGIONS!?
No one.
That’s who.
So it’s not surprising that the Martin jetpack
uses ducted fans rather than fire to lift
the rider off the ground.
Another problem?
The noise.
The roar of the engines simply make it too
uncomfortable to use.
Plus you can’t exactly sneak up on your
enemy if they can hear you from miles away.
Also physics.
Lift force must exceed weight force.
and really the whole reason we haven’t had
jetpacks yet… is humans just aren’t made
for flying.
We’re awkward creatures and not very aerodynamic.
To get us to fly, the pack would have to do
all the work.
Which means a lot of fuel, which means the
pack is just too heavy.
So you’d need a lot of fuel to lift a person.
LIke the army tested a jet pack in the 50s
that was only airborne for about 13 seconds,
which burned up 25 pounds of rocket fuel.
To make a flight last long enough to be enjoyable,
you’d need more like 890 pounds of fuel.
That doesn’t even factor in that the engine
would have to be more powerful to carry all
that fuel adding more to the total weight
of the thing.
It gets real problematic real fast.
One of the possible versions of a jetpack
is the Bell Rocket Belt which uses hydrogen
peroxide as the fuel.
But there’s another big problem.
Hydrogen peroxide burns fast and hot.
But because it burns so fast the flight time
is only about 30 seconds.
and with a hefty price tag.
It can cost as much as 240 bucks a gallon.
Since the flight time is so short, you really
can’t get high enough to the point where
a parachute can catch your fall.
So use at your own risk really.
So yes, jetpacks are here.
They’re nowhere near perfect, but with a
little more innovating maybe they’ll get
there someday.
Speaking of innovation, Intel creates the
breakthrough technologies that make amazing
experiences possible.
Having Intel inside makes for better experiences
outside.
Intel drives innovation with products like
processors, wearables and IOT devices, and
within data centers.
In the PC and beyond.
Got any clever ideas for an awesome jetpack?
Let us know down in the comments below…